this music that like turned me on to is
called country music when has a country
hit right now we ever do it
google quarantined cuties and Gwen
Stefani and Blake Shelton's pick might
just come up
I feel really just so grateful I feel
really inspired on Monday Blake appeared
on The Tonight Show Home Edition video
chatting with Jimmy Fallon from his
ranch in Oklahoma where he's staying
with when we are quarantined with a
bunch of Stefani's oh yeah and a bunch
of her family
he's like my hat by the way yeah get
closer I can't see it
I drank today no we do you know same
Blake same wins learned how to bake
bread really good sourdough bread we're
just literally it's like you know it's
Little House on the Prairie out here
like she makes bread I've been building
fence and gardening and there's pretty
self-sufficient out here well that's
when when popped in and explained that
she was booked to give her man a haircut
and just because he was mid interview
well that wasn't gonna stop her today we
had already scheduled that it was
haircut day so yeah the interview just
kept going while Gwen gave like a pretty
epic mullet as the most do this to you
the greatest all-time greatest country
star lake it is mullet perfection
business in the front party in the back
dude you are so Tiger King right now you
have no idea a source told et on Monday
that quarantine eing together with the
kids has made Blake and Gwen's
relationship stronger than ever quote
they decided that separating themselves
from the city life was best for their
family right now they feel blessed to
have a home they can
scape to during this difficult time it
is such a change of pace for everyone
and it's truly helped to remind them of
how important having family time can be
the source added that the duo has been
writing music together and Blake's even
been working on Gwen's dream garden um
cute and if that wasn't cute enough the
source said Blake has been getting in
some serious quality time with Gwen's
kids they have been spending time
fishing camping and roasting
marshmallows they love just playing for
hours in the woods they're living a
quiet life in the country right now it's
incredible to have a best friend like
that guy he's amazing okay so their
quarantine game is strong AF and so is
there flirting game on Monday Blake went
live on instagram with songwriter shane
McAnally who co-wrote Blake in Gwen's
new duet nobody but you
[Music]
and Glenn was all over it leaving some
pretty freaking cute comments left and
right exhibit a I want to make out with
flake Exhibit B
Blake why do you gotta be so cute and
Exhibit C Blake do you want to hang out
with me when also gushed over the
success of nobody but you her first top
ten country hits which just keeps
climbing the charts quote Blake thank
you for letting me be on your country
song it's going to number one soon it
was literally written for us which plus
I'm sure each one of you writers on the
song wrote it about your your own
personal experiences and that's what
makes it you know that song so great
that's what makes for a great song is
when you can take it and and kind of
apply it to your life and it fits so
perfectly I I tell Gwen all the time my
favorite my favorite part of the song is
when you left someone they say you said
I'm free but that it worked for me
because that's always been such a such a
standard understood way of thinking you
know when you love something let it go
but I've never really thought about no I
just I'm sorry if it's selfish but I
just I can't I mean but really if you I
mean if you really love someone that
much who the hell wants to do that I
mean and we both love that part of the
song you know so much it just hit home
with us
[Music]